[Music]
we have prepared joique on color
variations neon blue neon red and this
is the joy con strand it is a wrist
strap you can slide onto the rail like
this and it has a prominent L and our
buttons for firm pressing it's great for
games that have you swinging your hands
attaching to your wrist so you won't
drop it and it makes the joy con easier
to grip this is the type that will come
with your Nintendo switch system but
there will also be other colors sold
separately the right joy con also has a
motion IR camera that can sense the
shade motion and distance of objects in
front of it it's right here for example
it can tell the difference between rock
paper and scissors and it can tell how
far away the hand that through it is
this will make unique new control styles
possible what's this it feels like
something shaking in a glass
the joy Khan can convey to you the
feeling of ice cubes colliding in a cup
you can even tell one two three how's
the number of ice cubes in the glass
that I knew and you can feel water
filling the glass on jakku Tomas this
new sense of realism is produced by the
position of the new HD Rumble Yoko
we cool with these new sensing and
vibration technologies the joy con
itself boasts an expressiveness that
invites the player to pick out the
controller the joy Khan offers more than
just traditional video game controls it
invites everyone to a new world of
entertainment
elmerita allow me to introduce you to
two new games made possible by the joy
one that everyone can play together
that's and one with DES my challenge and
replayability first let's switch to the
game everyone can play it together